COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I take App Engine's new
scheduling flags for a ride.
Will we buck the
performance trend?
Stay tuned to find out.
Now, one of the nice aspects
of "the cloud" being a platform
is that over time it'll
grow, change, and improve
itself, which is exactly why
we're talking about App Engine
instance count again.
See, since our episode last
year, the App Engine team
rolled out a brand
new scheduling system
to help you get even more
control over how and when App
Engine spins up instances.
So of course, I wanted to
dive in, kick the tires,
and see how some of
the new settings works.
But first, I wanted
to get a baseline read
on how the scheduler
responds in the same tests
that we used last time.
Once again, our server
code is pretty simple.
It's just a simulation of a
CPU intensive application.
Obviously, if you have a
four-second response time,
you've got bigger
problems to worry about.
As a baseline,
here is 1k queries
per second, which the previous
scheduler shows differences
between the new one.
We can see that without
touching any settings,
the new scheduler is already
performing just a little bit
better for my contrived
scenario, which is good,
because it means that
without lifting a finger
we get a little better
on instance counts.
Next, is something I've been
interested in for a while--
min and max_instance settings.
Max instances, of course,
defines the upper limit
on the number of
instances you can have,
which is helpful to
control your costs,
while min instances ensures that
after deployment there's always
a certain number of
instances running.
But before you set
this flag, make
sure you take into account how
your minimum instances count
interacts with your
idle instances count,
since they are two
very different concepts
and you don't want a
lot of spare instances
lying around when
you don't need them.
Make sure you check out the
article in the description
below for more details on that.
Anyhow, next up is the target
throughput utilization flag,
which sets a threshold for the
number of concurrent requests,
after which more
instances will be
started to handle the traffic.
This flag works hand in hand
with max_concurrent_requests
to determine your true number
of requests per instance.
For throughput-heavy
applications,
lowering this value will result
in more instances being spun up
to handle the work, while
increasing this value
will let each instance better
handle the connections,
and in most cases should
reduce instance count.
Now, finally is the target
CPU utilization flag.
This flag defines the
CPU utilization ratio,
which defines when a new
instance should be spun up.
Or perhaps a better way to say
it, if your app is CPU bound,
then this is the
parameter you tweak
to optimize between
performance and costs,
since lowering and
raising it can impact
how many instances
you spin up in order
to handle the workload.
With an improved scheduler
and a new set of settings,
App Engine gives you
much better controls
to better balance between
performance and costs,
which in my humble
opinion is always
the spot you want to be in.
If you'd like to know
more about these tests,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]